à marioupol également se sont
actuellement à 400 mille civils qui sont
bloqués dans le secteur une ville
anéantie par les frappes la situation
humanitaire sur place ne cesse de se
dégrader le maire de marioupol alerté
tout à l'heure sur notre antenne écouter
la situation à mario paul sur le plan
humanitaire ne fait qu'empirer il n'y a
plus d'approvisionnement les gens n'ont
plus accès à la nourriture et aux
médicaments aux sanitaires l'accès à
l'eau est difficile la situation
s'aggrave chaque jour
comme si chicharito des prêts
sur le plan militaire l'armée
ukrainienne défend la ville avec succès
et parvient à faire face à l'armée russe
mais nous n'avons pas la possibilité de
défendre nos vies des attaques aériennes
lundi il y a eu 22 frappes aériennes sur
des cibles civiles partout dans la ville
sur les structures médicales des
immeubles mais des écoles
bo de ce qu ils ne font que bombarder la
ville et ils la détruisent